مقابله اجراها عبد الجواد الرشد مراسل
العربيه في موسكو الحرب بين روسيا
واوكرانيا غيرت الكثير على ارض الاخيره
وايضا في الجاره الغربيه لاوكرانيا بولندا
الان تنظيف بولندا لتصبح قوه عسكريه في
القاره العجوز بشراء احدث الاسلحه
الامريكيه بولندا وبسبب موقعها
الاستراتيجي وبسبب اهميتها في الازمه
الاخيره ما دفع محللين لاعتبارها اكبر
المستفيدين من الحرب الاوكرانيه بولندا
جزء من الجناح الشرقي للنيتو والاتحاد
الاوروبي كما انها المنفذ الاكبر من
اوكرانيا لايصال المساعدات العسكريه
والانسانيه اليها خلال هذا العام زاد
بولندا مخصصات الدفاع باكثر من 4% من
الناتج المحلي الاجمالي كما وقعت قانونا
يزيد من حجم جيشها باكثر من الضعف ليصل
الى ثلاثه الف ثلاثمائه الف جندي اضافه
للتوسع في عمليات الشراء الاسلحه بكمي
ضخمه مقارنه بالدول الاوروبيه الاخرى ثوره
الانفاق العسكري في بولندا لخصها وزير
الدفاع ماريوش تشاك في امله بان تصبح
بولندا اكبر قوه عسكريه بريه في اوروبا كي
لا تهاجمها روسيا الوزير اعاد التذكير بان
بلاده لطالما حذرت لسنوات من التهديد الذي
تشكله روسيا على دول الجوار واستشهد
بتحذيرا من الرئيس البولندي الراحل
في اعقاب غزو روسيا لجورجيا عام 2008
عندما قال اليوم جورجيا وغدا اوكرانيا
وبعد ذلك قد يكون موطني بولندا في مجال
التسلح يتم استبدال الاسلحه القديمه التي
تعود الى الحقبه السوفيتيه والتي تم
التبرع بها لاوكرانيا بانظمه اكثر تقدما
من الناحيه التقنيه بولندا وقعت صفقه
باربعه مليارات وسبعمائه وخمسين مليون
دولار لشراء دبابات ابرامز الامريكيه في
صفقه كانت قيد الاعداد قبل حرب اوكرانيا
كما اعطت الولايات المتحده هذا الشهر
الضوء الاخضر لحزمه اخرى تصل قيمتها الى
عشره مليارات دولار بما في ذلك نظام
الصواريخ هاي مارس وصواريخ تكتيكيه طويله
المدى بشكل عام الاسلحه الامريكيه الجديده
ليست الاضافه الوحيده لبولندا اذ ان
الولايات المتحده او لها نحو 11 الف جنديه
تمركزون شرق بولندا علاوه على ان المقر
الدائم لقياده الفيلق الخامس الامريكي
يوجد هناك
[موسيقى]